Our vehicle is constructed
from foam with carbon fiber
reinforced wings.
It has a single control
surface at the tail,
which is controlled by
a hobby servo motor.
For our experiment, we will
only consider the aircraft's
lateral planar dynamics.
For tracking the
aircraft's position,
we'll use a VICON
motion capture studio.
We will define our
perching maneuver
as the aircraft
starting 3.5 meters
from the perch at 7 meters
per second and landing
in a 6.5 centimeter
capture region
with less than 1 meter per
second of forward velocity.
We demonstrate the
robustness of our system
by throwing the glider by hand.
Landing on power
lines to recharge
provides a unique opportunity
to improve the mission duration
of unmanned aerial vehicles.
In this project, we
explore whether or not
we can successfully
perch on a power line
with a fixed wing UAV using only
the magnetic field generated
by the power line to
localize the aircraft.
These results demonstrate that
magnetic field based estimates
are sufficient for achieving
closed-loop perching
and could be a reliable
means of perching
on powerlines in the field.
Finally, we take our power
line perching glider outdoors
and demonstrate that we are
able to perch successfully
in outdoor environments
when wind is limited.